now i haven't done a video on
microwaves i want to give you my opinion
and anything that i say that
conflicts with what you know if you've
found some studies or references that conflict
put it down in the comments section below i'm
always interested in new research and especially
research that's been suppressed because when
you evaluate anything on the internet a lot of
times you'll find that information is suppressed
a lot of the facts are not easily found i mean
let's take for example crisco it's been considered
somewhat healthy for 97 years until they
found out it's actually pretty dangerous right
so there's a lot of things in the market for
a long period of time considered safe so i'm
just going to give you my opinion on microwaves
i do have a microwave oven i don't really use it
it's not that i'm concerned about it i just don't
use it because i use the oven mostly so let's just
kind of go through some definitions here the
definition of radiating means traveling outward
in all directions from a source okay then we have
radiation which is the transmission of energy
in the form of particles or waves through space
or a medium like food a body or even a wall
and so some people have this
consideration if they microwave the food
that it's going to be now radioactive in some way
let's close it up right now there's actually two
types of radiation you have ionizing radiation and
you have non-ionizing radiation ionizing radiation
breaks one or more electrons from the atom
it's deeper it can create dna damage and that
would be like gamma rays or x-rays or even to some
degree uv radiation but then you have non-ionizing
radiation which can disrupt bonds of molecules
but not necessarily the atoms but in the research
of microwaves apparently it doesn't even break
the bonds it just vibrates the bonds so it might
disrupt the bonds in some way and it creates heat
so that's really how microwaves affect the food
they're vibrating the food to a certain degree
which creates heat all right so microwaves
can lower the nutrient value in food for sure
depending on how long it's being microwaved but of
course heat in general lowers the nutrient content
in food the big problem with microwaves is what
you cook your food in if you're using plastics
the heat is going to break down that plastic
and put it in your food and there's been
some pretty hardcore research on this and
our bodies are accumulating a lot of micro
plastics and this is definitely one source so
if you're going to use a microwave cook in
glass or ceramics okay but don't use plastics
in a microwave now the other very important point
about microwaves is that you do not want to stand
anywhere near the microwave oven when it's on
now usually they have a little filter in there
with those little dots do not be looking in the
microwave when you're cooking anything in fact
i would walk away to the point where you're
not even 15 to 20 feet in the direction
where that microwave is and the reason is this
because those waves coming from the microwave
can affect the cornea of your eye and
the last thing you want to do is vibrate
the small molecular structures of your eye
and start to cook the lens of the eye which
is very sensitive to heat so you just want to
be completely away from the microwave and a few
days ago i used my emf tester on the microwave
i wanted to see how far these waves extended
from the microwave when it was on i had my emf
set to radiation waves and it was definitely
significant at 15 feet away from that microwave
so if you're going to use a microwave stand all
the way to the side be away from the microwave hey
before you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today